I said I'm gonna come to life but I
can't this is your brother's side his
name I have a very special person here
with me somebody who just did an
interview with me this is a brother I'm
sure you've heard of him I'm sure you've
seen his videos there's so many Muslims
that have benefited from doula Eddie
with the Dean show check this out said I
want a COO Eddie
assalamualaikum warahmatullahi better
care - may the peace mercy and blessings
of the Almighty be upon you how you guys
doing salami
mashallah lads it's so amazing spittle I
know brother Eddie he interviews
everybody but I wanted to interview him
I'm gonna ask him a few quick questions
in the shelter and I actually I caught
him off I caught him off guard he didn't
know I'm gonna do this but I was like
I'm here Eddie's here let's ask them a
few questions Eddie I know you interview
a lot of people and you hear a lot of
inspirational stories in here about how
people came to stem and what they went
through is that would you say that's one
of the ways that you have managed to try
to maintain your email and increase your
emails to have that can real connection
with real Muslims and their stories when
you look at this phone that you're
recording with the cameras that we just
use they got a certain battery life and
that battery life gets drained right and
then it's worthless it's not good and
you had you had mentioned a hadith where
the peroxisome talked about the heart
there's a there's a morsel of flesh in
the body if it's sound the whole body is
sound
the fuel the battery life is the for the
Iman is the knowledge and I get to sit
with people like yourself with people of
knowledge hearing these wonderful
stories of people accepting Islam I get
empowered right
many people would and I talked about
this today when you don't get empowered
by the owner of power Allah the Creator
it's temporary its weak and I find that
when I when I'm able and this is what
hamdullah were going on over humble lot
10 years over 500 episodes Russia and
it's like my life my heart comes to life
again may now we go up and down and when
I'm when I'm able to recharge you know
through knowledge I always I always try
to make sure if I'm in the car you know
suppose a free time I like to you know
do things with the kids family or not
but I tried to make sure that it's not
wasted time I make sure that I'm
recharging and through the things that
that you know every time you're reading
a book you're listening to a lecture
you're listening to a talk and dialogue
about Islam something that has to do
with the Dean you're in the lost time
clock you know that right yeah right
you're actively bother yeah and it's so
much different than sometimes you can
get caught up into doing something
that's a waste of time and you're not on
a lost time you're not getting rewarded
for that time and then the mass starts
it starts affecting the heart right
you know what's kind a lot what what
Eddie mentioned I get this question a
lot of question by Iman like how do I
maintain my Eman and I'm always like
Eman is not it's not an on and off
switch right this is not like on or off
it's our day to day stuff you know like
constantly working on our Iman and
that's why you know I think it's it's
amazing that you know what all the
content that Eddie has out there you
know even if you and this is this is a
personal testimony and you know it
doesn't no I was gonna say this but just
listen to some of these interviews and
revive your Eman right none of us are
perfect or remount isn't always gonna be
at 100% but we need things like this we
need knowledge we need inspirational
stories we need experiences and that's
why you know the Quran is full of what
stories write stories why because that's
a means of inspiration for us real quick
Eddie I'm not gonna keep this long but
if you could share with us one story one
incident from your life and I know I'm
putting you on the spot I apologize for
that but something from your life that
you know you found to be inspirational
or that helped you out in Xiaohua
the the moments motivation inspiration
is usually when I sit down with
different individuals there was a
Hispanic brother not too long ago I did
it I did a program because we talked
about when I interviewed you about
getting burnt out a lot of times people
who are you know everyone has to to at
some point you might have an Arabic we
got a Muslim name and then you're just
going through the rituals right taking
it for granted yeah and what what
happens is when you see the struggle
that people have gone through to come to
Islam this brother was kidnapped asking
about calm in Mexico so I ended up this
brother went through all sorts of trauma
and drama until he just was like God
wherever
you are beceause whatever you are just
guy me if you don't if you don't guy me
I just gonna and I see this when I talk
to people I see this when someone opens
up their heart and they just ask
something so basic and so simple but
people they go around the world and back
and they don't do something there's
brilliance and simplicity Allah has made
it simple and if you ask Allah for
guidance he will facilitate away and
this brother and I see so many people
and I get touched by this
I see how the struggles that they had to
endure and how much more they appreciate
the deed they appreciate it it was like
God just wherever you are I don't get in
there with the Buddha's with the Hindus
so whatever you are just guy me if
you're in Buddhism if you're in Hindu
who is that if you're just guide me and
I'm gonna open up that door and they
were so Pete so many people who stuck it
out a lot tested and tested there's some
serious sincerity and they're still with
us strong today I get inspired by that
that motivates me so what you got to
complain about look at that man these
people who I just you know look anything
that's worth anything is in the ground
it's deep in there so people have with
the Islamophobia machine it's a 200 plus
million dollars annually it's spent to
debase Islam throwing dirt on it so not
test you see you got a dig a little bit
you got a sign you're gonna find that
treasure like without digging what's
awesome work so Allah knows you put just
amount of the amount of work for a size
that you have to do but if you're
sincere and when I listen to these
stories I think that inspires me that
inspires me to keep more keep doing what
we're doing to share these that
hopefully now you can get inspired by
hearing all their people's trials and
tribulations like wow hamdulillah you
know I'm so thankful for this blessing
it's a price islam is a priceless gift
don't lose it don't lose it appreciate
it live it get empowered by it and these
are the kind of things that every week
30 minutes a day
every Friday we put out a new
show of people who've been empowered by
Islam by this beautiful way of life
experts who talk about you know many of
the different dilemmas the Islamic
phobia challenges how to deal with it in
the best way
tune in tuning you what do you got to
lose nothing but so much to gain that
clock head brother Eddie you know that's
a such I'm so glad you mentioned that
because sometimes we think you know if
my mom's not going up with this or that
particular thing then you know what's
the point
you never know what will be the source
of your iman going up it could be a
video it could be a conversation and we
just got to be conscious beings we got
to have our hearts open it's not a lot
had brother Eddie I'm not going to hold
you up for too much longer I want to
shake your hand Simon have to switch
hands just spin it now let's try this
oculus head brother Eddie and I make the
odd that I lost my toe blesses your
efforts and keeps you going and I ask
everybody who's watching this to keep
watching brother Eddie's Dean show Allah
bless him lol bless all of you take care
we'll sit on what a comb
[Music]